cancer is caused by the uncontrolled
proliferation of cells cancer cells are
hungry in order to meet their demand for
the nutrients and cellular building
blocks that enable them to grow and
divide rapidly their metabolism changes
new insights into these processes have
sparked interest in developing drugs
that target the unique metabolic
characteristics of cancer cells such
drugs have the potential to treat
cancers arising from many different
tissues while leaving normal cells
relatively unaffected the altered
metabolism of cancer cells includes an
increased uptake of nutrients such schoo
COEs and glutamine also they start to
metabolize glucose in a slightly
different way a phenomenon called the
Warburg effect in all cells glucose is
broken down in several steps to pyruvate
in normal cells most of the pyruvate
enters the citric acid cycle in the
mitochondria which effectively act as
the energy factories of the cell in this
way most of the glucose that is taken up
is completely oxidized to carbon dioxide
in the 1920s Otto Warburg discovered
that cancer cells unlike most healthy
cells metabolize most of their glucose
using biochemical pathways that do not
require oxygen regardless of whether
oxygen is available excess glucose is
taken up and like in normal cells broken
down to pyruvate however instead of
entering the citric acid cycle
most of the pyruvate is converted to
lactate which is secreted from the cell
it is still controversial why tumor
cells employ this relatively inefficient
way of extracting energy from glucose
one theory is that the process reflects
a metabolic program that cells use to
convert nutrients into the building
blocks of matter
molecules cells can be viewed as
molecular factories and glycolysis is
not the only aspect of the cells
metabolism the resulted in cancer cells
cancer cells undergo a general shift and
catabolic two anabolic metabolism in
order to produce the greatly increased
amounts of proteins nucleic acids and
liquids they need to support their high
rates of proliferation cancer cells also
take up amino acids amongst these
glutamine is of particular importance it
act as a key source of nitrogen which is
required for nucleotide and new amino
acid synthesis in some cancer cells due
to meat also acts as a critical source
of carbon which is required for
replenishing the components of the
citric acid cycle many anti-cancer drugs
on the market have metabolic targets in
the cells although for a large
proportion of them the metabolic target
was only recognized long after the drug
was developed for example the widely
used chemotherapy drugs 5-fluorouracil
and gemcitabine interfere with DNA
synthesis today there are a multitude of
approaches in development that aim to
target different aspects of cancer cell
metabolism for instance scientists are
exploring the possibility of blocking
glutamine to interrupt the supply of
carbon and nitrogen they're also
considering other enzyme targets that
might limit the use of nutrients to make
key building blocks some strategies are
aimed at interfering with the high rates
of glucose metabolism and lactate
secretion as described by otto warburg
anti-cancer approaches targeting tumor
metabolism faced many challenges a major
one is finding the therapeutic window to
prevent toxicity to normal tissues
however it's become clear that the
genetic changes associated with cancer
can create addictions to specific
metabolic pathways which can be
therapeutically exploited moreover
cancer cells can be more sensitive to
metabolic perturbations than normal
cells due to the loss of cell cycle
checkpoints a better understanding of
how metabolism is altered in specific
genetic context that lead to cancer will
help scientists identify enzymes or
combinations of enzymes to target for
intervention and hopefully allow the
creation of more effective anti-cancer
drugs